If you're a writer who cares about your
readers, but you don't have a clear,
proven system that'll help you translate
complex ideas into cohesive linear pros,
then it's very likely that you'll end up
like so many writers who focus on all
the wrong things that'll never get
readers to actually read your text. So,
in this video, I'm going to give you the
exact system I use to help my clients
organize their ideas from a messy draft
into a crisp manuscript, all without
losing the original meaning and without
losing your voice to AI. I've broken it
down into six parts. So, as this video
goes on, it's going to get more and more
valuable. And for those of you who
already have 50 unpublished drafts saved
somewhere on your hardware, this could
be all you need to get unstuck and
finally publish work that you're proud
of. So to start, who is this system
going to work for? Well, it's not going
to work for fiction writers or memoir or
poetry or any writing that doesn't make
a point? But if you do use your writing
to make points, which means answering
questions or solving problems either for
yourself or for your readers or just
more generally if you're using writing
as an extension of your own thinking,
then it can. So this week, for example,
I used this strategy on two very
different clients. One was an academic
researcher who's applying for a grant
worth over €200,000.
And the other was a clinical
psychologist who was drawing on her own
kind of unorthodox background experience
to try to make a new point to pretty
clinical researchers in her field. So
there we have two very different types
of clients who are writing in completely
different genres. But the thing that
unites them and the reason the strategy
works is because both of their
manuscripts were pointed. They were
trying to make a point and make an
argument about that point to basically
convince their readers of that point.
And so the reason the system works for
both of these different types of clients
and the reason they came to me for help
is that when your writing has stakes,
you can never edit it yourself. There is
a common piece of uh writing advice,
particularly common in the world of
fiction, which says whenever you are
writing a draft, you should take a day
off or two days off and then read it
over because what you want to do is read
it as a stranger would. But that's
actually impossible. And I mean that
scientifically. So there was a study at
Carnegie Melon University which
demonstrates the very fact that it is
impossible to proofread your own
writing. And it goes like this. And so
in this experiment, they prepared a
document about a pretty technical
non-fiction subject. So think a
scientific report or um a kind of
breakdown of some technology and they
filled the document with these errors,
structural errors. So we're not talking
about like a misplaced comma or a
spelling mistake. We're talking about
logical gaps, inconsistencies between
ideas, the these kind of more macro
structural issues. And then they gave
that document to two different groups of
people. But this one group, they
actually briefed on the subject. They
gave them essentially background
knowledge and told them some of the
information that would also be relayed
to them in the document. Whereas with
this other group, they just gave them
the document cold. Who do you think
caught more of the errors? Well, the
fact is it was the people who read it
cold that caught the errors. The readers
who had been briefed on the subject
essentially used their background
knowledge to skate over the logical gaps
and basically fill in those gaps with
what they already know. Because they
brought this background knowledge to
their reading experience, they weren't
able to notice the logical gaps and
flaws in the text in a way that a cold
reader could. And the point of this
experiment is to show that you are
always the briefed reader of your own
draft. You're the one who wrote it. And
of course, you had the idea before you
wrote the text. Like you were thinking
of the idea, whatever it is that you're
writing about, and then you're the one
who chose the words to represent that
thought. So whenever you read your own
words, you are never in the position of
a reader who is interpreting just based
on what you've given them. Readers have
a pretty hard job. They need to look at
your words and then kind of build this
edifice. And if you write well then the
edifice that they've built in their mind
matches the one that you had in your
mind. But the problem is when you're
reading your own writing, you're not
doing the same interpretation. You're
not converting words into symbols into
this edifice. You're just remembering
the edifice that you already have in
your mind. And so if you're just relying
on your intuition or just waiting for
some time to pass between when you wrote
something and and when you edit it,
that's why you're running into problems
with your editing. And so instead of
relying on your intuition, what you need
is a step-by-step system. And this is
exactly the system that I run with my
clients. And so we start here. And so
this is kind of like an abstract
representation of a text. You know, it's
Lauram Ipsum. So we have some paragraphs
and a block quote here and the title,
but it kind of represents any
non-fiction genre. And so what's the
first step you want to do? The first
thing that I would have you do is
essentially underline whatever you
consider to be the introduction and the
conclusion and just ignore everything in
the middle for a second. Now, the reason
I have the writer or the client identify
whatever they consider to be the
introduction is that sometimes the
introduction can span over, you know, a
few paragraphs or a few pages. So, we're
not just talking about like the first
sentence. It's just whatever you
consider to be the opening preamble to
that section. I want you to underline
that. Okay. Now, we have two sections.
And so, now that we've identified each
of those sections, the next thing to do
is underline the sentence that you think
best captures the point of this section.
And so the reason that we do it at the
introduction and the end is that
whenever you're writing, you've probably
done your best to articulate the point
in your introduction. But whenever you
are doing expert writing, whenever
you're answering questions or solving
problems, whenever you're basically
using writing as an extension of your
thinking, you move through the text in
time. And so you start off with kind of
a vague idea of what your what your
point is going to be. But as you work
through these ideas, as you bring in the
evidence and you analyze it and you
know, you kind of string these things
together by the end when you hit your
conclusion, usually the point here,
although it's the same point, is going
to be a lot more refined. And so that's
why I like to just isolate the
introduction and the conclusion at the
beginning and find the most important
sentence in each of those and just
compare them. First of all, check are
they making the same point, right?
Because we do you do want your essay to
kind of have this um feeling of closure,
right? You don't want it to be making
some wildly different point than you did
at the beginning. Now, that doesn't mean
repeat the point from the introduction.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the difference between an introduction
and the conclusion in just a moment, but
for now, just analyze the two sentences
that you consider to be most important.
And I have an example here for us. And
by the way, these are just model
sentences. So, I've chosen the topic to
be personal essays because I work with a
lot of personal essayists. So, we're
going to talk about Joan Ddian and James
Baldwin. But it says during this
unprecedented period independent
essaists shared the process of creating
a new public intellectual culture
through their accounts of personal
experience. So it's all about bringing
personal experience into the essay
genre. That would be the point from the
introduction. And now contrast it with
the point that we find in the conclusion
because this is what a lot of the points
in the conclusions look like by
contrast. It says, "While many were
eager to slash the essay's ties to the
argumentative tradition, Joan Ddian and
James Baldwin wrote pieces which kept
the machinery of argument visible and
which made that machinery a central part
of the personal essay's new authority."
So, of course, that's just an example,
but this is generally what I find that
the point we discover in the conclusion,
if it is the same point, that's the
first thing you want to check. But if
they're both making the same point, then
generally the one in the conclusion will
be more refined. And so just examine
these two sentences and say which one do
you think is more pointed? Which one is
sharper? Which one is more refined? And
of course, you can also synthesize them.
So if you find them quite different, if
this one is missing pieces that that one
is missing, you can bring them together
because what we're doing is essentially
trying to make the central point. We're
trying to kind of draw out of these the
strongest elements and bring them into
one crisp point sentence because the
next thing that we have to make, the
next decision that we have to make is
where to locate it. And so we're just
carrying this over here. So here's the
introduction, the conclusion. We've now
synthesized these into this point
sentence. And we have the choice of
placing that point sentence in the
introduction or here at the bottom. And
the diff generally of course you're
going to put your point uh at the end of
the beginning if that makes sense. You
know here um if this is the introduction
paragraph then we would generally find
the the thesis or the point to be toward
the end of the beginning. But sometimes
you can put it at the bottom here and
that's what I would call point last. So
here's the difference between them. With
a point first essay you're quite
familiar with this. You know you just
have your introduction paragraph put the
thesis down here and that's
conventional. that's what your reader is
expecting. But if for whatever reason,
if you decide that you want to hold off
on delivering the thesis, you can do
that. Uh this point last structure, you
see it sometimes in more creative
non-fiction, especially not necessarily
with the entire with with the point of
the entire essay, right? The thesis will
almost always be in the introduction.
But if you scale this down as a fractal
pattern into um you know just a section
then you'll often see authors kind of
hold off on delivering the point until
the end. And the way that you can do
that with point last structure if you're
go like if you're going to put the
thesis or the the main point down here
in the conclusion then you at least need
to give the reader a preview of where
you're going. It could be a promise but
at least a thematic kind of introduction
of the key concepts so that by the time
they arrive at the conclusion they have
a sense of closure and of inevitability
and of cohesion. So the way that I'm
kind of representing this is that um
some I've kind of looked at this point
sentence and identified what are the key
concepts in it. And so for the sake of
this example, we've said that argument
uh the personal essay and the new
authority, those are important concepts
in this passage. And so therefore,
whatever we put in the introduction, we
want to save for the end of the point
sentence these three concepts. These are
called key terms. And ideally you would
I mean depending on how the essay goes
but ideally you would have one po one
one section here about argument one
section about the personal essay one
section about new authority because
that's it's almost like a chord if you
think about it like music like an
arpeggio or something and like once you
once you assemble these three disparate
notes into well strum them together you
get a chord. So by kind of developing
them independently like that or by
introducing them and then developing
them independently you can then weave
them all together strike that chord and
that becomes quite uh pointant and as I
said inevitable. So that's point last.
As you can see it's a little bit
advanced. Do it if you wish. Um but
generally what your reader is expecting
is to find the point of your essay right
here at the end of the beginning. And so
now that we've set the frame of your
essay with the with the beginning and
the end and we've put the point where
the reader is expecting to find it. Now
what we want to do is apply a very
similar strategy to the section the the
units within the essay. And this
structure is quite important you know
because if you when when structure works
it's almost invisible. And you know this
I mean pick your favorite writer think
of your favorite non-fiction book. It is
structured. It it does have a structure,
but I bet you as the reader spent no
time noticing it. Okay. So, when
structure works, it's invisible, right?
It it it it's what allows the reader to
kind of step into the logical world that
the book is trying to open up or the
essay or whatever it is. So, that's the
goal. Now, what are some signs of bad
structure? Well, no structure is a
pretty bad sign. And when when that
happens like when you don't have any
logical principle when you know if you
and I were to meet if I were to say to
you why did you organize it this way and
you can't tell me then you have a flabby
kind of amorphous document and it's a
little bit like pudding like you know
there might be raisins somewhere in here
but the reader is not knowing where to
find it and that can be a pretty
frustrating reading experience. So you
do want to organize things logically,
not in some struct I mean I think
structure can really emerge from the
text and that's usually the way that you
want to do it. What you don't want to do
is organize things according to the way
that they occurred to you. I've spoken
elsewhere about the difference between
writing patterns and reading patterns.
And when you organize your paragraphs
just and the sections just in the order
that they occurred to you, you are
working within the domain of writing
patterns. And readers don't really know.
They're not interested in following your
own intellectual journey. They're not
interested in the order with which they
occur to you. Readers have questions
like they see your point that prompts
them to ask a question. they're
expecting the answer to their question
to occur at the at the moment when it
occurs to them. So whenever you're
organizing these, you need to think, you
know, not in any rigid organizing
pattern such as uh chronology or even
these kind of clunky like sometimes
writers will still not have any logical
organizing principle, but they'll say
first, second, third, right? They'll add
to the start of their major points
first, second, third. That's not an
organizing principle. That just means
that you have three of something. So
here here's how we do this more
practically. So I would ask you to then
ignore the introduction and conclusion
and just draw a line between the
sections. So in this example in these
three pages, let's say that we have two
sections. And just as before, I'm going
to ask you to underline the one sentence
that sometimes it can be two or three
sentences. Sometimes you've kind of
distributed the point across um two or
at most three sentences. But underline
the point that you think articulates so
perfectly the the point of this section.
And if you can't find it, you have
problem. You might need to rewrite it.
But here, the way that I've represented
it is, you know, we have the the point
here occurring at the beginning. And
then in section two, the point is just
kind of occurring in the middle. And so
just as before, we want to put those
points where the reader is expecting to
find them. So that is in the index
position at the top of each section.
Now, in a moment, I'm going to show you
how to develop the um the remaining
text, you know, because we've just like
extracted the points from your draft and
we've put them up here. So, what do we
do with the rest of the stuff that you
wrote? We're going to look at that in
just a second. But one thing to notice
is that between the in between these
sections, so between the introduction
and this and the section one here, we
have a transition. And then again
between section one and two, just a
transition. That can be its own
paragraph. It can be just the last
sentence in the final paragraph. Format
it however you wish, but it is nice to p
kind of round up and push off of that
point that you just finished making in
the section and lead in. And it can
often be a question. Actually, I think
this is like um writers can sometimes
overuse rhetorical questions, but it can
be a kind of pallet cleanser because the
question is such a sharp break in tone.
Um, in the English language, there are
four moods. So, generally we're writing
in the declarative mood where we're
we're making statements. Um, but there's
also the interrogative mood where you
ask a question. And that doesn't often
happen in writing because they can't
actually respond. And so if you use it
sparingly and only to transition between
points such as okay now that we've
proven this point you know ask the next
question the next logical question that
arises especially if it mirrors the
reader's own kind of thinking patterns.
You know if if this is the question that
the reader is now asking and they see
the text ask it they feel understood and
it's a great way to push off.
However you want to do that, just make
sure that you're transitioning. And now
let's think about how to organize the
material in the discussion. So whenever
you're making a point, it's important to
understand the kind of anatomy of a
point. And I've represented it here. So
you have a point and that point is you
know somebody might ask you why. So um
you know here's here's a sentence and it
says Orwell would have opposed AI
assisted writing. Let's say that's your
point. Well, the next question that the
reader is going to have is why would
Orwell have opposed um AI assisted
writing? And so the next thing that you
need for a point to be valid is a
reason. You need to be able to say point
because and then give some rationale.
But of course, you have to imagine if
you're making a point, it also means
that somebody else is wrong. So whatever
your point is, you have to imagine that
somebody out there is going to disagree
with you. Otherwise, what's the point of
your point? There's no point. So for
every point there needs to be a reason.
And for the person who disagrees with
your point, they're going to attack your
reason. That's why I've represented it
as a triangle here because if they don't
like this, then this is what they're
going to attack. And that's why your
reason always needs to be based on
evidence. And now evidence varies by
genre. with the earlier I mentioned a
clinical psychologist who I'm working
with and she is drawing her kind of body
of evidence is her own personal
experience that's why it's a little bit
unorthodox for the the genre but with
the academic I was working with it's the
evidence is from his clinical labs and
from data that he's pulled from uh
certain research so it all depends on
your reader and your genre of what
counts as evidence you need to think
about what kind of evidence is the
reader going to accept but For every
point, there needs to be a reason and
evidence. That doesn't necessarily need
to be three sentences, but you at least
need at at a kind of higher order, you
need those three elements to have an
idea. And so assuming that you have all
three pieces kind of, you know, spread
out throughout this draft, we need to
start checking to make sure that the
evidence provides a real foundation for
the reason and that the reason does
support the point. And so here's just a
quick kind of example of what happens
when you start mapping out your ideas in
this kind of a structure. So if we read
this point again, it says Orwell would
have opposed AI assisted writing because
as he said, good pros is like a window
pane. Now I don't know if that raised an
eyebrow for you, but this is the kind of
thing that we generally see whenever we
start slotting your ideas into this kind
of a structure. We see points that kind
of are are plausibly supported by the
evidence, but we we don't really see the
there's a logical gap between them. And
that's exactly the thing that becomes
evident to your reader. It's exactly the
thing that these people in the Carnegie
Melon experiment noticed these guys when
whenever you're you're a reader, you're
outside of the writer's head. You're
just kind of trying to assemble these
ideas using the clues on the page.
Logical gaps like that become very
apparent. Now, if I ask the writer
about, you know, the structure of these
ideas, it's going to be obvious. It's
like, well, of course he would. You
know, he said good pros is like window
panes. So you say what is the connection
between good pros is like a window pane
and AI writing. What how do how do you
do that? And so by mapping out your
ideas this way that helps you kind of
see and check the logical strength and
integrity of your points. And so after
teasing this out we might find a passage
more like this. Um, Orwell would have
opposed AI assisted writing because he
judged pros by whether a reader could
see straight through it to the thing
described. And borrowed phrasing leaves
a film on the glass. That is the
standard he set when he said good pros
should be like a window pane. Okay. Now
again, this is just an example, but it's
the kind of thing that would satisfy
this structure because we built a bridge
from the point to the evidence. We have
an explanation. Now, if you disagree
with that explanation, if you disagree
with the point, then now you actually
have something to attack. But the point
of this is to show that previously we
didn't have that bridge. And so there
was no connection between the point and
the evidence. So now that we have kind
of mapped out the logical structure of
each of these points, we can start
filling in that discussion section. And
of course, there are all different kinds
of ways that you can do this, but a
useful pattern of development here is
called the uneven U. Now, this comes
from Eric Hyatt. He's an academic and he
wrote about this in a book for the
humanities, but I think this is useful
across all non-fiction writing. And so,
what does this show? Well, notice I I've
mapped on to this uneven U, the
structure that we've been talking about
here with the index and the discussion.
So what this measures is the uh level of
specificity over time. And I think
generally whenever you are writing a
paragraph or a section or any piece of
pointed pros, it's going to have a
pattern of progress like this where we
begin at level four. So we have five
levels here. Down here is something
specific and concrete. That's your exam.
That's your evidence. That could be a
quote or a statistic or whatever
evidence that you're using. And then up
here we have the kind of mo most general
kind of abstract level of discourse that
you could think of. And so if those are
the poles, then ideally you want to
begin at a level four, not level five.
If you begin at level five, it it it's
kind of so vacuous that it like it's not
even a point. It's just true. So, we
need to come one level down to make sure
that we're beginning with something a
little bit specific. What's a good test
of level four? I generally say it's
something that someone else could
disagree with. All right? So, it's level
four means it's falsifiable.
Somebody else could say, "What? How
could you say that?" Okay? If if you
look at that kind of point sentence in
the index position and nobody could
disagree with it, you don't really have
a sharp enough point. But if you do,
you're ready to progress. And I'm going
to give you an example of it down here.
But just to kind of map it out
abstractly, what you want to do
essentially throughout this pattern of
development is to stay on that point,
but kind of progress down to level three
where you are explaining what you mean,
elaborating on it, and drawing yourself
closer to the evidence. Now, level two,
that's where you start preparing the
reader for the evidence. So, for
example, if you have a quote, uh maybe
there's an important concept or key term
in that quote. Well, try to use an
analog or like a close synonym of that
key term at level two to kind of prepare
the reader for it. Why do we do it this
way? I think it's because it's really
hard to process very specific
information. Um there there's one, you
know, piece of advice I see floating
around sometimes is to like open with a
surprising statistic or or a surprising
quote. I'm saying the opposite here.
Like I think that's a really terrible
way to open a point because it's so
specific that the reader has no context
for interpretation. So they don't really
like you can give them the idea, but
they don't really know what to do with
it. So instead the uneven you guides you
to uh lay the kind of conceptual
foundation so that the reader is
prepared and ready to interpret the very
specific information at level one. But
the important thing here moving forward
is that we don't drop them here. You
know in the book they say I say um it's
a book on academic writing but they have
a great section on what they call the
hitandrun quotation. And I think that
happens a lot. Writers will kind of, you
know, maybe uh they they'll do the first
half of this properly, so they'll move
move from general to specific, but then
they'll just drop the reader that kind
of inverted triangle. They'll just drop
like drop them with this highly specific
information and say, "Do what you want
with it." Well, no. We don't want to do
that. We've now prepared the reader to
accept this information. And so now we
give it to them and now we want to start
helping them weave it back in to the
conceptual thread the foundation that
we've laid out here
effectively in a you know a good section
we are more or less saying something
like this here. Here's my point and
stick around because I'm going to I'm
going to prove it to you. All right. So
this thing works like this and that
reminds me of a pretty good piece of
evidence and here's the evidence. And
so, as I was saying, that evidence shows
us this. And so, as I told you, this
point is true. And so, we we return to
the point. And not exactly to the point,
but to the same level of abstraction.
We're not just this doesn't mean just
repeat what you said at the beginning,
but it does mean return to that
conceptual level of the idea before
finally pushing off to a more general
level of resolution than where you
began. Why is that? Well, imagine it
playing out over this, and I'm going to
give you an example in just a moment,
but imagine this pattern of development
playing out in this section here. So,
we've made the kind of thesis and now
we're introducing one of the finer
points of that thesis. Well, we bring
the reader down. We give the evidence.
Now, we're coming back up. Well, we
don't just want to say, see, told you
so, right? At at the end of this
section. We don't want to say so, you
know, as I said, what we want to do is
push off of this point. So, this is
rounded off at level four. And now we
want to link it back up to level five to
a more general level because this
section one is a subpoint of the entire
thesis. So we want to now that we you
know we say we make a promise. I'm going
to show you this point. We do all the
work. We prove the point. Now we come
back up. We say see I told you the
point. And here's how that helps us
answer this larger question that we're
trying to answer. Something like that.
Of course there are all different kinds
of ways that you can do this. It's so
abstract that it's hard to get specific.
But down here I I have written a kind of
model example and I've labeled what I
think are the different levels of
resolution. So see if this makes sense.
This says AI assisted writing would have
been distrusted and probably opposed by
plain style writers like George Orwell
who judged pros by whether a reader
could see straight through to the thing
he described. The greatest threat to
that that clarity he thought was
language the writer had not chosen. His
standard is made in the famous essay why
I write. Good pros should be like quote
a window pane. But the sharper statement
comes in another essay from the same
year on politics and language where he
describes bad modern writing as strips
of words already set in by someone else
gummed together like the panels of a
pre-fabricated hen house. The complaint
in these passages is that ready-made
language lets a writer finish a sentence
before having arrived at what it means.
But where Orwell saw the problem of
language without thought exemplified in
the cliche, it has become a general in
the era of AI which offers fluent
phrasing before the writer has settled
on a thought. The precedence of clear
pros over clear thought shows us that
Orwell's window was never a test of the
formal features of the text. It was a
test of which comes first, the window or
the vision. Now, it's always risky as
like the writing teacher to give you
examples of my own writing because you
guys are just going to roast me in the
comments. Look, I was trained in
literary criticism. So, it's the kind of
thing that might work better in my field
than in yours. And just try to think
creatively about how you would use this
because I think this pattern of
development, whatever your genre, works
because it kind of it gives the reader a
nice experience of specificity. Like,
you know, in here there are actually two
level one statements. There were two
quotes that I brought in. So, it was
kind of like level two, level one, level
two, level one, and then up to level
three. And that's important because
we're now like we're staying on the
evidence. We're not dropping it, right?
The level three sentence says the
complaint in these passages is that
ready-made language lets a writer finish
a sentence before having arrived at what
it means. So, we're interpreting the
quote. We're weaving it back in to the
point that we've been trying to make.
We're not dropping it. That's the point
of the hit-and- run quotation. Whenever
you introduce some highly specific
information, don't just drop it and move
on. Weave it in. Show the reader how it
links to the point that you're trying to
make. And then don't just finish at that
point, but push off to a more general
level of resolution. And now for the
last check that you'd want to run on
your writing. It is the certainty. You
want to make sure that your points are
not being made too stridently, but at
the same time, you don't want to be so
mely mouthed that there's nothing at
stake and there's not really any
argumentative energy in your writing.
And so I have here the same point and
I've written it three different ways and
we're going to measure it using this
scale down here with hedged on one side,
uh, stridident on the other, and right
in the middle well calalibrated. So the
first one says, "Every plain style
writer would have condemned AI assisted
writing outright. Orwell judged pros by
one thing only, whether the reader sees
straight through to the thing
described." And no sentence produced
this way ever passes that test. And so
sometimes writers who write this way can
actually be kind of fun. Like they they
can be they there's a lot of moxy in
this kind of writing and they can be
very pointed, but you really have to
earn it. And so in this case it it kind
of verges on the on the end of um
arrogance I think because you see all
these qualifiers right it says every
plain style writer would have condemned
right AI assisted writing outright
whenever you see these kinds of
qualifiers like too many of them stacked
up those are usually um I actually made
this point in a lecture earlier this
week is that whenever we're in a
critical thinking class and students
were saying well obviously this and of
course that and common sense. And
whenever you see these things, it's
actually usually a sign, al although
they're meant to signal strength and
confidence, what they're usually filling
up is a lack of argumentation. And so I
think that's what we see here. Orwell
judge pros by one thing only, right? So
these kinds of things make the piece a
little too strided. So contrast that
with the same point written differently.
It says for some time now many writers
in the plain style tradition might
arguably have been somewhat wary of AI
assisted writing and some of them may
have perhaps opposed it since figures
like Orwell seem to have generally
judged pros at least partly by whether a
reader could more or less see through to
the thing he described. So obviously we
are now at the other end of the
spectrum. There are so many hedges in
this piece that it's almost meaningless.
Like it's it's so hedges are words, you
know, like for some time now, many, not
all. Uh they might arguably have written
partly, right? These kinds of things
soften the level of confidence. And of
course, you need to do that. You do need
to modulate the strength of your claim.
But if you go too far in the other
direction then you appear to uncon like
it's it's not scientists generally write
this way because they want to be
cautious and precise but at that end of
the spectrum the reader loses all
confidence in you and so what you want
is a balance between them and there's an
important strategy so see if you can
notice what balances this last example
so it says writers in the plain style
would have distrusted AI assisted
writing and Orwell almost certainly
would have opposed it. He judged pros by
whether a reader could see straight
through to the thing he described. And
drafting that begins with unchosen
phrasing puts something in the way. And
so that is what I would consider a
calibrated sentence. And so how do you
do this on your own pros? Well, look at
the verb and look at the subject. So the
common advice for hedging your writing
would be to look at the verb. So, for
example, the the overly hedged passage,
we see like when you look at all the
verbs, you see might arguably have been
somewhat wary, right? The the verb is be
wary. They would have been weary, but
might arguably have been weary. So,
that's the common advice and it is good
advice. You need to choose like rather
than using all these modal verbs like
might arguably have been somewhat,
right? All those just choose the right
verb. And again with AI and and or you
can use a thesaurus there there's no
excuse. There are so many verbs out
there to perfectly capture your meaning.
So if you notice the kind of buildup of
all of these modal auxiliary verbs just
find a better verb. But the other thing
to look at is the noun, right? By
narrowing the noun that lets you
strengthen the the your kind of
confidence in the claim. So again when
you look at the hedged piece and you
look at the subject of that noun or the
sub the the noun in the subject position
what you find is we're hedging also in
the subject position right for some time
now many writers in the in the plain
style tradition right by contrast look
at the stridident version it says every
plain style writer so if you're properly
hedged if you're if you're well
calibrated then you're going to have a
very kind of narrow
noun not something that's kind
overloaded with all these modifiers,
right? It says writers in this style
would have distrusted and that's fine.
Now, at this stage, you don't have a
perfect essay, but you do have the bones
of it. You've put all the important
parts in the places where readers expect
to find them. But the next thing you
need to do is make sure that your
readers have a smooth experience when
they're working their way through your
sentences and paragraphs. So, watch this
video next because it's going to give
you four paragraph patterns that'll
imbue your pros with a sense of flow.
So, be sure to go check it out.